[Music]
[Applause]
courage is like character
something you build up in small degrees
from the day you were born
as a firefighter on the front lines the
building was just almost completely
involved
dennis smith who died last week at the
age of 81 had courage
and he had something else
a talent for riding that turned him into
a best-selling author of books about the
firefighters world
it began in the 1970s when a letter he
wrote to the new york times book review
caught the attention of an editor who
encouraged him to chronicle his
experiences working out of the city's
busiest station in the fire ravage bronx
the first book report from engine
company 82 would sell over 3 million
copies and was translated into a dozen
languages 15 more books followed
including 2002's a report from ground
zero
following the 9 11 attacks
smith became a celebrated figure but
life didn't start out that way
growing up in an irish-american
neighborhood on manhattan's east side
smith dropped out of high school when he
got arrested for fighting a judge
offered him an alternative to jail
joining the military he served in the
air force and said that helped turn his
life around three years later he started
his career as a firefighter
in 1981 smith retired from the fdny but
continued to write and remain an
advocate for first responders around the
globe the idea is in firefighting you
can trust everybody almost all of the
time he had five children
and enjoyed playing the bagpipes one of
his six musical instruments
he died in florida after being diagnosed
with covid while battling an illness
related to his time at ground zero he
said he remained a firefighter at heart
and never forgot his thoughts on his
very first day on the job so here i am
looking up at the towering yellow brick
building of engine company 82
and i'm hoping i have whatever i'll need
to fight the fires that i know will be
before me
[Music]
what i love about dennis's story is he
got a second chance and he shined with
it yeah that judge
gave him a shot that's great report from
engine company 82 is so great visceral
brutal but awesome yeah